ehrlich also darf man früher ans freibad
einmal benutzt denn anni und heute mal
auf den sitzen acht eindeutig was geht
ab und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut
wir sitzen ja gerade haben musst auch
mal warten wir mal ein paar donuts
probierten der leute das ist das
heftigste video also das müsst ihr euch
eigentlich rein ziehen wobei ich mir
unsicher bin welches video zuerst kommen
weil ja gerade zu dieser zeit jeden tag
um 19 uhr ein neues video auf dem kanal
erscheint denn natürlich jeder von euch
schon abonniert hat die glocke optimiert
und mit instagram gefolgt das heißt sie
mich viel werbung mit na ja heute
irgendetwas noch heute ich habe nämlich
noch ein adventskalender über 50 euro
adventskalender von boxee dann haben sie
mir zur verfügung stellt schöne grüße
geht daraus mal wieder und das ist
eigentlich ein kalender auf den ich mich
von allen am meisten gefreut hat weil
wir haben in diesem kalender wohl nur
sachen drin
die aus den 80er jahren stammen
beziehungsweise den 80er jahren halt
trend waren ich weiß nicht ob es nur
süßigkeiten sind oder es waren die 70er
jahre
wir werden sehen ich mache jetzt erstmal
auf und da bin ich mal gespannt zwei
kölner habe ich auch schon ausgebracht
werde ich euch gerne jeden kurzen
ausschnitt ein werden einmal einen
veganen kalender und wir hatten einen
fuß auf usa kalender genau also mit
amerikanischen süßigkeiten das immer
besser
deshalb reicht es also geiles ding okay
also ich bin mal gespannt kann der was
ich habe dann irgendwann nichts zu sehen
das sieht es gut aus gesteht nokia viele
leute 24 in nostalgische leckereien und
süßwarenproduktion fotos sieht gut aus
design ist wieder richtig heftig 40 euro
kostet der ich bin euch hier super gerne
ein foto von 1
ich weiß ja dass mittlerweile auch zum
teil ältere leute meine videos schauen
die vielleicht schon in den 80er jahren
geboren sind also wir werden dann ist
das ja was für euch wobei ich sagen muss
von dem produkt wurde da waren 23
süßigkeiten die kannte ich auch weil ich
die früher gegessen
ich habe natürlich dass ich verweile
hatten auch noch weitere ist eigentlich
unser aufgestellt an kommen das finde
ich ein bisschen schade ich lese gern
kommentare und ich habe bis jetzt noch
in keinem kommentar gelesen alex dass
auch ein schild das ist richtig toll
woran liegt das das ist doch mega oder
das ist ein wichtiges aushängeschild für
meinen kanal und die leute draußen
hängen immer hier ist ja so klingt auch
das ältere herren
na ja gut dann machen wir jetzt mal den
kalender auf ich bin auch gespannt
welche ich noch vor weihnachten dessen
darf deswegen wenn ihr da irgendwelche
ideen habt oder irgendwelche produkte
online findet was jetzt adventskalender
betrifft dann schickt die mir auf dem
programm
instagram alexia wie schon gesagt wir
fangen an mit der 1 weißt du was ich
glaube ich habe das irgendwie für alle
die wir bis jetzt hat die sind gleich
angewandt wird das heißt die 14 und die
sechs war doch auch schon beim letzten
da oder wer kennt die kenne ich das
morgen meine zeit kannst du nicht diese
muskeln die man nutzt das sind die
heftigsten ehrlich also davon probieren
freibad einmal benutzt habt so nennt man
die
und dann zum nachteil einer medizin
kommt davon wenn nur so kommen wir zu
natürlicher nummer zwei also das erst
natürlich und fand ich schon richtig
heiß weil ich habe die muschel ich
dachte gar nicht dachte mir jetzt gar
nicht mehr muss natürlich nummer zwei
hatte ich mir von euch schon will ich
die zwei gesehen die kenne ich noch die
kenne ich nicht das sind brause stang
europa die sind sogar mobile die die
sind sogar probiere ich gleich also
interessant das ist bis jetzt der
interessanteste glaube ich also ich habe
richtig bock schon das wetter
auszuzahlen die nummer drei warte mal
habe ich das schon gesehen hier guck mal
die sieht man aber echt was nicht ist
dass ich ihren kalender von 90ern
also ich glaube dass schon achtziger
oder neunziger keine ahnung
youtube habe ich noch nie gesehen ist
das ein langgezogener lol ja
guck mal dicker als das denn kurz danach
traten auch die spinne ist einmal eine
pfeife also dann richtig lecker delikate
dass die heutzutage nicht mehr so im
trend liegen habe ich kenne ich nicht
hätte ich mir früher gern gekauft ihr
könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
schreiben was er nicht kennt und was ihr
kennen die nummer 4 der melone mini
suite das kaugummi belohnung
ich kann nicht weg er kann man nicht
einfach belohnt nein die gab es anders
ich kenne die auch schon früher waren
aber auch so ein schild verpackt dass
man die fünf suchen die firmen habe ich
auch schon gesehen genau hier war die 14
ja nichts neues kennt doch jeder ist
kennen die kinder heutzutage doch sogar
schon diese ketten gibt es die wohl auf
als tauss sieht man das diebesgut aus
dann machen wir weiter die nummer 6
suchen wir kaufen ist das denn
und vor allem wir jetzt auf ist ein
richtig ist kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das so eigentlich noch
nicht auf der welt war dass die kids das
richtig gefeiert haben kennt ihr das
schreiben die kommentare ich kein
schnick und wie sollte man hier
eigentlich runterschlucken aber muss ich
jetzt wurde euch das auch früher mal
gesagt wenn man kein wunder schluckt
verklebt der magen stimmt nicht mein
mann ist die verklebung ja auch so viel
runtergeschluckt
ok macht es einfach mal hintereinander
auf 7
na gut das ist ja absolut nichts neues
[Musik]
was jedoch eigentlich auch drin sein
müsste wer preis oder wo ich glaube ich
habe der kaugummi zigaretten
da man erkenne ich glaube ich oder das
kenne ich auch noch die kenne ich auf
jeden fall echt geil habe ich auch schon
ewig nicht mehr gesehen
man erinnert sich dann erst jetzt so
wieder an diese teile warte ich hab mir
grad was krasses gesehen was machen das
ist dass ihr zeit kaum mit zigaretten
da kenne ich natürlich auch oder kennst
du noch diese schokolade zigaretten
davon habe ich früher auch so viele
gegessen da waren wir noch mal kugel
kunst auch im rhein cruisen dann kam
sogar aus ging das ja ja weil das staub
drauf liegt das ja ja weil da staubt
dass sie in der grundschule gemacht
die kenne ich alter die mutter habe ich
ja eh wenig gesehen
die habe ich früher mal beim friseur
bekommen genau und manchmal gab es beim
friseur die nicht mehr da war ich
richtig traurig das war eigentlich der
hauptgrund warum ich zum friseur
gegangen wird damit ich diese löcher
kriegt ihr war ich mir auch center shop
führt dann auch mal langweilig centers
of kennt jeder
das ist auch absolut meine kindheit
gewesen crazy tipps kann sein dass es so
ist aber da muss ich was ich das jetzt
von text es nicht jetzt sollte auch
jacksons breite so dann steckt man sein
fuß hier rein und der fuß kommt so
wieder raus mit so ein paar dicke dinger
dran gibt es das heutzutage wir haben
das früher mal eine tankstelle gekauft
an tankstellen das heute nicht mehr
ich habe es nicht mehr gesehen so schade
schade die 21 ich habe mal hier
mister global darauf vor mit der spd das
wahrscheinlich so eine brausetablette
sollte mein motto jetzt nicht die nummer
14 war es ja babbel kann das sagt was
eigentlich auch noch das finde ich ist
dass das
darüber kann man aber das war auch so
verpackt jaja da sind dann ist das
tattoo ja das kannst du auf oder kann es
noch mal auf reisen
keine ahnung hier kann ich auf jeden
fall nochmal weiter auf 16 10 und die
120 euro
die 24 doch irgendwie gleich hier in 20
liga ich hab letztens mal richtig an
diese lommis gedacht weil ich die früher
auch mal habe ich meinen blumenladen ob
sie also kommen da durfte man sich immer
wenn man im blumenladen war gab es diese
leute und dann habe ich die letzten aber
hier bei uns im supermarkt gefunden
genau diese packung hätte ich die packen
da jetzt nicht jetzt ist gewonnen wenn
ich verstehe jetzt richtig ausgerastet
und ein paar sachen haben wir noch
magica kenne ich auch könnt ihr krass
dass man eigentlich alles davon kennt
und es mit der zeit zu wieder vergisst
das kennen mich ist wahrscheinlich
zitrone ja gut das kann auch hier kann
ich auch die kann ich auch schokolade
hat mir noch gar nichts mehr eigentlich
außer dass jetzt knapp pfennig für macht
total eklig diese dinger das war's
eigentlich sehr einfach
naja ich dachte schon genau die haben
gefehlt da bildet ja ja die habe ich
letztens sogar irgendwo mal gesehen ich
glaube hier gibt es auch jedem
supermarkt ein neuesten und nochmal
melone oder muscheln haben wir noch
ja auch komisch finden könne
kennst du das sieht aber gut aus und
hier diese lohnen auch nicht was die
laden wo ich immer meinen yu gi oh
karten körper diese also eigentlich kann
man schon fast sagen das sind alles
sachen aus den neunzigern oder außen
außen 2009 würde ich mal sagen weil es
gab jetzt nur sehr wenige sachen die ich
nicht kannte
aber der kalender ist warte mal ich muss
ich muss ich hoffe dass mal kurz doch
nach immer sagen sie das zu helfen hier
steht
nostalgische vorweihnachtszeit für 80er
90er 2008 da haben wir sie angepasst
praktisch also ein paar sachen kann ich
nicht kommen dann wahrscheinlich aus den
80ern ein paar sachen aus den 90ern ein
paar aus dem 2000 leute war richtig geil
hat richtig spaß gemacht den kalender
außen banken wenn er was für euch ist
linke mache ich euch in die video
beschreibung wir sehen uns morgen hast
du wieder aber nicht den kanal ins warum
alex pietsch